hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the finals of the asian rapid gold
money tournament it's levon aaron versus
vladislav
and this is game three the game that
basically ended before it started after
the first two games and you've seen how
crazy the second game was it was
an incredible clash that lasted uh
forever even though it's a rapid game
uh but this game it's much much
different so without further ado let's
check it out
uh you uh you you will enjoy this one
all right so here levon opens with the
d4 much like uh
much like he did in the first game uh we
have d5
knight to f3 bishop to f5 c4 and e6
again we have this baltic defense that
our team have used in game one knight to
c3 and
knight to f6 we have knight to h4
attacking the bishop and
now bishop back to g6 but now uh you can
see that levon uh
played without without this e3 and
allowing black to play c6
so here he go goes queen to b3 right
away and now you don't have time for b6
a c6 because your b7 pawn is hanging so
here you have to play something
uh here uh we have uh oh and also queen
to b3 is a new move
aside from this known moves are some
like knight captures on g6
and there is a game daniel dubo played
against yanni ponchi
where g3 was played that game ended in a
draw but here queen to b3 is a new move
so already as of move six we have a
completely new game
uh we have knight to c6 trying to give
up this pawn
uh and the problem is if you capture a
knight captures on d4 and black wins the
c2 square is defended twice by the
bishop and
by the knight so not much to do here for
white so instead
after this knight to c6 we have c
captures on d5
we have e captures on d5 and now just
the com e3
we have bishop to b4 by artemiev and now
knight captures on g6
eliminating this monster bishop we have
h captures and now bishop to d2 so just
nicely continuing development
artemis castles here and levon says all
right bishop to d3
uh even though instead of castling king
side he could have maybe gone maybe some
queen to e7 in castle queenside but he
decided to go kingside
we have bishop to d3 and now rook to e8
and here
white just castles and now uh artemis
decided to play bishop captures on c3
usually when the position resolves
itself and white decides the castle
the the bishop really doesn't have
anything to do on b4 you can just bring
it back to d6 but here
he decides to trade it for the knight uh
we have bishop captures and now rook b8
defending his b7 pawn
uh levon plays rook eight to e1 brings
the rook into the game now you can start
advancing f3 e4
and so on and now as uh artemiev has a
double jeep on he can start pushing one
of them
as he doesn't need both of them he he
just waits for whites to create a
weakness and then he can advance and
maybe
uh do some damage so here f3 and
now comes queen to d6 developing the
queen connecting rooks
we have a3 and now artemis goes for it
g4
uh so it's a reasonable move you want to
get rid of your doubled pawn and you
want to trade it off
for white's f3 pawn so queen back to d1
uh and
now artemis captured an f3 but g3 i was
also worth considering because uh you
you either get uh
captures captures and then you have a
queen on g3 or
white can advance the pawn maybe to h3
but then this is just a very very strong
pawn it's going to be here for a very
long time
and could cause quite a lot of problems
but artemis decided to capture
we have rook captures now a very nice
rook lift um
now helps out with the defense of the
backward spawn but also you can just
shift it to g3 or h3 if needed for the
attack
uh we have rooked the e6 artemiev also
wants to double up on the e file and the
bishop to f5 now
i live on using this move to improve the
position of his own bishop
so rook to e7 the rook will also be very
nice on e7 as
it will add additional support to the f7
pawn since uh you pretty much know the
one is doubling up on the f file
we have rook e to f1 and now rook beat
the e8 now putting pressure
on this e3 pawn so queen to e1 defending
the spawn
and now knight the e4 so what do you
play here
uh well levon says all right essence
you've allowed me these squares uh
and the there's nothing guarding these
squares i'm just gonna play queen to h4
and now uh you can see that uh there
could be problems the rook can come to
h3 and how are you how are you defending
against checkmate
and here basically the only good move
for black is just uh
and knight to f6 doesn't help because
they're squint h8 checkmate as well
uh so here uh queen to h6 would have
been the only move
uh because then we can just trade
captures capture so we can eliminate the
knight here
the captures and rook g3 check and the
problem is this dark square bishop is
just a monster you can't really go to
this diagonal then we just play d5 and
that's enough for a win you'd have to go
here but then rook g6 and then you pick
up this pawn
and it's uh it's a really really bad
position for uh
for for black to play if you play
something like rook to e6 you try and
handle it just
rook characters and then after rook
captures we even played d5
so not much to to look for here for
black but instead of that
after queen to h4 you don't really have
a good defense for black uh we have g6
bartim but now
uh this is completely lost so feel free
to pause the video and
try to find this instant move uh for
levon
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on completely
ignoring levon's last move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
of course
the movie is rook to h3 and this is only
move 23 and uh
black is completely busted there is no
defense against queen to h8 checkmate
uh levon tried queen to f6 he did he did
guard against the h8 uh
square uh threat but now just queen to
h7 check
uh you don't want to trade queens of
course king to f8 and our bishop
captures on e4 and he was in this
position on move
25 yes you've heard that correctly uh
that
uh vladislav resigned the game and the
game three goes to levon
which means he is now leading the first
match game of the finals
and everything will be decided in game
four will he remain the leader or will
uh
vladislav bounce back and everything
will be decided tomorrow
so here you resign because you're down a
piece uh and you can't recapture because
your queen is hanging and if you play
something like this you have to keep an
eye on this square because the checkmate
is coming
we can even play bishop captures on g6
so this is completely unplayable for
black if queen captures we're just going
to play rook captures
and that's it next we're going to
capture here this cannot be defended and
you know just incredible so after that
brilliant game one and an incredible
game too uh vladislav
really underestimated levon's attack
here with the white pieces and
of course uh once you allow the one to
start lifting those rooks
it's not going to be it's not going to
be a pretty sight for you
uh so yeah that's game three hope you
guys enjoyed it we'll see if artemia
will bounce back
uh i would like to thank glenn sassan
connor clark james walker peter milner
and wolfgang schmidt for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
until it ends so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day